[موسيقى]
لقب باكثر الرجال حكمه في العالم القديم
الفيلسوف اليوناني الشهير سقراط ابو
الفلسفه الغربيه وواضع اسس المنهج
السقراطي في هذا العالم ولد على الراجح في
العام 470 قبل الميلاد لاب عمل نحاتا
درس الجمباز والموسيقى والقواعد وخدم في
الجيش واشتهر بانقاده حياه الجنرال
الكبيادس في معركه بوتيدا واشتهر ايضا
بحده ذكائه وقوه ذاكرته
تعلم اسس الفلسفه على يد براميليدس وعمل
فتره من حياته في النحت والفن قبل ان
يتفرغ للفلسفه والسياسه
ابتدع سقرا طريقه للتحقيق والتعليم في
الفلسفه تتمحور حول مجموعه من الاسئله
للوصول الى نتائج واضحه ومتماسكه عن شيء
يفترض انه مفهوم ضمنا من كل البشر
كما اشتهر باساماته في مجال علم الاخلاق
واليه تنسب مفاهيم السخريه السقراطيه
والنهج السقراطي
لم يترك سقراطو كتابات وجل ما نعرفه عنه
مستقى من خلال روايات تلامذته عنه ومن بين
ما تبقى لنا من العصور القديمه تعد حوارات
افلاطون من اكثر الروايات الشموليه
والماما بشخصيه سقراط
تلخص فلسفه سقراط في كونها ركزت على
الاخلاق وعيش حياه فاضله دون الاكتراث
بالتمييز الطبقي الذي كان سائدا
وكغيره من الفلاسفه الكبار كان الاستقراط
تلامذه واتباع كرسوا انفسهم مثله للفلسفه
والحب والحكمه واسسوا العديد من المدارس
الفلسفيه بعدها
اسلوب سقراط في نبض الطبقيه خلق له اعداء
حاولوا الضغط عليه ليتخلى عن افكاره الا
ان سقراط ابى ذلك وواصل مسيرته ليحكم عليه
بالهرطقه وافساد الشباب وحكم عليه بالموت
عبر تجرع سم قاتل في العام
399 قبل الميلاد عن عمر ناهز السبعين عاما
خلد الفنان الفرنسي جاك لوي ديفيد موتى
سقراط بلوحه فنيه تعد احدى اشهر اللوحات
في العالم
اشهر مقولات سقراط من صحى فكره اتاه
الالهام ومن دام اجتهاده اتاه التوفيق
[موسيقى]